en busca al noroeste de kiev el ruido de
los bombardeos ha sido substituido por
un silencio mortal y descubrimientos
macabros
para salvar su pellejo
vasili se escondió en un refugio durante
15 días ante el horror se esfuerza por
encontrar palabras
un tanque detrás de mí estaba disparando
perlas
los cuerpos yacen en el suelo la mayoría
de ellos son hombres jóvenes algunos con
disparos en la cabeza y sus manos atadas
a la espalda
el enemigo hijo sus regalos para
nosotros después de una dura lucha
puedes imaginarte la clase de energía
que han perpetrado aquí esta página de
nuestra historia la registraremos y se
utilizará cuando se les hundió me busco
puede ser mona prójimo efe tribunal de
lucha es una de las ciudades que acaban
de ser retomadas por los ucranianos
desde hace varios días las tropas rusas
se están retirando de varias localidades
cercanas a la capital y por primera vez
desde que comenzó la guerra las fuerzas
ucranianas afirman tener el control
total de la región pero están huyendo
intentan que parezca una redistribución
pero no lo es es sólo una derrota y una
huida se ha descrito en rne en el
presidente ucraniano matizó más para él
esta maniobra refleja el deseo ruso de
concentrarse en el donbass y el sur de
ucrania
volodymyr selenski volvió a pedir a
occidente que le proporcionará
equipamiento militar